hi I'm Melissa Camaro and I'm Randall
Park and we are here to take a co-star
test to find out how well we know each
other
[Music]
yes really yes
I think I have a memory of you eating
having a little hole yes and that's next
to you your chair oh my God that's crazy
lobster roll I don't know yes yes oh my
God oh my God it's a lobster roll it's a
lobster roll that was incredible okay
their first acting job oh I think I know
this
it's a One Life to Live yes yes
wait yours was it the injury no no no my
first like kind of network thing was a
show called Fast Lane oh and I just I
just had a line on it that was that was
my first like like TV TV yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah okay first time you
met each other was on zoom on Zoom yeah
yeah first scene we filmed together
we're seeing we filmed together uh was
in Timmy's office but I don't remember
what it was it was not the last scene of
the pilot I know that no I don't know
I'm gonna give it to us though I think
yeah yeah right yeah I think we got it
right their favorite movie they would
have ran it at a blockbuster when Harry
Mets out yeah we both that's the answer
yeah their dressing room must have
coffee
must have yeah water
[Laughter]
yes well I mean you need to stay
hydrated what was it
oh coffee as well I was trying to give
you a look of like like everything else
it's the same answer yeah yeah
where you find them in between takes on
his laptop in his chair yeah
on your chair on your phone yeah pretty
much yeah I mean we talk and we also
interact like you yeah yeah but this is
just when we're not interacting like
human beings yeah yeah at hour seven you
run out of things to talk about uh the
actor they want to work with the most in
the future oh that's a good one who's
yours
no
I don't know either I don't know we're
gonna skip that one yeah yeah we both
got that uh wrong their go-to karaoke
song
I have to carry out with myself
we're very similar we've established
this way before we even started filming
we're very similar oh their birthday
wait I know this uh because it's very
close to March
all right okay March 20th
23rd yeah 23rd yeah how did you know
that because Enzo's is the 24th oh
that's right that's right
um I have a uh Melissa is is truly
Timeless and ageless
so I don't even want to dignify this
question with an answer she is a uh uh
she is forever youthful and vibrant but
also I won
[Laughter]
so I yeah see I got nine out of ten
what'd you get I got uh yeah six out of
ten yeah I won yeah that was good that
was good yeah bye thank you BuzzFeed
thanks BuzzFeed and don't forget to
watch Blockbuster on Netflix
[Music]